PERIOD.
BRENDAN LEMIEUX, BLAKE LIZOTTE,
ARTHUR
TRYING TO THREAD THE NEEDLE,
SHUNIN FRONT OFF THE SKATE
UP.
BROWN.
BEATS ITT BACK, ARIZONA
STARTINGA CHANGE.
>> J PICK SOMEONE
COYOTES.
DZINGEL SHOT, KRAUSE GOES TO PO,
14 SECONDS LEFT IN THE FIRST.
NO SCORE,Y OUT OF THIS THING.
I THOUGHT THE CHANCES WERE THERE
IN THE ZONE.
BY KESSEL. OUT WITH IT CHARGE IN
DOWN THE RIGHT WING FOR ARIZONA
STICK CHECK FROM THE SKILL.
HERE'S THE TURNO
ARVIDSSON KOPITAR RECEIVES. ZON.
USE YOUR STICK, DO WHATEVER YOU
CAN, THE FACE-OFF.
DOWN ON THE G HERE.
>> SO KESSEL GETS THE REBOUND
B.
KOPITAR HE
KRAUSE DUMPS IT IN.
OPEN.  THIS IS MORE DIFFICULT TO
EC CUTE BECAUSEANG
BACK.EN MAATTA OVERSKATES.
NICE TO SEE THAT HE'S GETTING
MORE ANDZONA SKATES OUT OF IT,
SEND IT IN.
HARD UP THE
AWAY, CENTER DANAULT.
DENIEDNG PENALTIES,
KNOWN FOR A LITTLE BUT OF
SANDPAPER THERE WAS SOME FINISH
TO HIS GAME A
MOVE IN WITH THE SHOT OFF BY
VEJMELKA.HE BRAKES, HANDS IT OFF
TO THE ON COMING KELLER, DRIVING
WIDE OF THE NET, WRI
TOP AGAINST ONE COYOTE.
SO THE KNEE -F
LEMIEUX THAT GOES THROUGH HIS
LEGS AND HE GOES DOWN ON THE
PLAY. DEEP,
EDLE
WINGS IN OVERTIME.
>> 2-1 WINJOB THEY HAVE TO ANALE
EACH PLAY ONE AT A
THE CROSS.S IN.
>> I THINK IT'S IN TOO.
>> THEY PLAY ON.
>> I THINK IT HIT OUR POST